- So I love "A Mighty Win"
I love "Waiting for Guffman".
But here's my thing,
I laugh the entire time
and I don't
I know you're an actor
so like you're supposed
to be able not to laugh.
But how did you not laugh
in all those scenes?
- Well, I,
I did.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] You Did?
- I did, but what particularly,
in "Waiting for Guffman,"
because that was the first one
and because Chris Guest,
who I kind of co-wrote the movies with
and Chris directed them
and Chris is one of the funniest guys
ever.
- [Kelly] You're not so bad
yourself, yeah (laughs)
- Well, he had my number,
let's put it that way.
So his character, Corky St.
Clair, was just so funny
that every time he was on camera
I would laugh.
He would get me laughing.
So, there was a group of
us in most of the scenes
and I would move myself behind the group
as the scene was being shot,
drop to my hands and knees
and crawl off the set
(audience laughing)
so nobody would notice
that I was laughing in
the middle of the scene.
And I would virtually disappear.
And--
- 'Cause you don't want
to ruin this scene.
- Well that's the thing.
- Yeah.
- Because it's improvisational in nature,
you know, what your
doing that's really funny
off the top of your head,
it's really hard to
- Recreate.
- go back
and recreate that if you laugh
in the middle of a funny scene.
Then they say, "Cut!
"Okay, boy, that was going so well
"let's go back and try that again,"
it changes things.
So we learned
it's better not to laugh
no matter how funny you
think something is--
- That's a talent.
- But in "Waiting for Guffman"
I was crawling off the set
more times than you can count.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my god, you're like
that Homer Simpson gif
that just backs up into the bush, like
like, I just got to not ruin this.
- That said,
- That would be so hard!
- Well, backing up into the bush,
that was like in Guffman.
There was one scene that
was one of my funniest scenes.
It's a group where
we're on stage during our final show
at the end of the movie
and a train is supposed to be pulling away
and what we do is,
we're standing there watching the train
and we kinda go like this.
- (laughing) No!
- Yeah, all right.